well if you're hip to the ironic nature
of the moment we're living in this will
not shock you but it's still pretty
amazing
a group of self-described free speech
organizations have now come out in favor
of government
censorship this is happening in a lot of
places here's the latest example
the group pan america which has been
around for a while
fighting for the right of writers to
speak their conscience in public has now
decided that's a bad idea so they sent a
letter to the white house announcing
they're forming a
coalition of quote human rights free
speech democracy and technology
organizations all of those are false
except technology
they're not for democracy free speech or
human rights they are for technology
and that's why the coalition is urging
the bid administration to quote
create a disinformation defense and free
expression task force
to target the crisis of disinformation
that threatens our democracy
in other words when you say things they
don't like when you utter forbidden
facts
that's against democracy you thought
democracy was the right of every person
to be represented by a government
who democracy is the right of a very
small group of people to control
everything
just so you know charlie kirk is the
co-founder of turning point usa and a
friend of ours he joins us tonight
charlie great to see you so i you know
you kind of lose track of all the
orwellian moments in the past
couple of years but the pen america
coming out for censorship has got to be
at the top of the list
yeah tucker i was actually going to say
why don't they just call it the ministry
of truth and just get it over with yeah
at this point it's as if 1984 is just
the instruction manual
this goes to a noam chomsky quote that i
obviously agree with him on very little
politically which is totally true
which is the way to have a population be
obedient
is to guard rail the acceptable opinion
so it actually makes sense that these
free speech organizations are the ones
that are engaging and not free speech
but instead
refereed speech which is that we believe
in robust debate
as long as you allow us to be the ones
in charge be the umpires
of what you can say and not say and then
there's this very vague term
intentionally of disinformation
and so then they want the federal
government to now have the power
to criminalize speech and this really
what it's going after of course it's
about control of course it's about
totalitarianism
but this playbook has now been used by
these activists
to pressure social media companies you
saw what happened today with facebook
and to pressure the tech elites to then
pander to the most radical left-wing
voices in our country
and i gotta say if republicans don't
wake up to this sometime soon
we are not going to have a republic or a
country because republican
republicans have just sat idly by while
these activists
have steamrolled our rights over now
that's right you make such a smart point
about guard rails
you can have any conversation you want
as long as it's within the parameters
that we said that's why we just
interviewed marcia taylor green
because they said you can't really up
yours of course we can we do whatever we
want we're journalists it's america
but so many people fall for this like
you that's one thing you can't talk
about
really why do we play along
well and and we're playing along because
so many of us
we we have something to lose so i think
they're actually using
our really nice lifestyle against us so
many people across america are saying
you know i would speak out
my kid might not get into college i
would speak out but i might lose my
country club membership i would speak
out
but i might not get a bonus from some
corporation
so they are using our very comfortable
lifestyle against us
and until americans start to realize
that this is going to cost you something
to to actually speak your mind and have
some courage and again they want to
limit the spectrum of acceptable
political opinions
and in so far we play by their rules we
are always going to be playing catch-up
that's why we must actually be the true
ambassadors of free speech
not refereed speech charlie kirk who
does not get the credit he deserves for
thinking deeply about this stuff i
appreciate you're coming on tonight
thank you
thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else